what's your
in your opinion the best game you ever
played
probably the um probably the game
my actually my um my freshman year in
college
freshman year in college we were playing
texas a m and
back then they had the best defense in
the country and i was a freshman
full-back
and i was scared i was i'm very i was
scared and i remember it was like
the first end of the first quarter they
ran a blitz and we ran a draw play and
they kind of ran themselves out of the
play and i just broke up the sideline
for a touchdown and i was so like so
shocked that i had that i had a nice
play
and i ended up finishing the game with
165 yards and two touchdowns and we
we beat them and won the conference
championship that's great so that just
as a freshman showing up against the
you know putting up a buck 60 yeah wow
what what's what's your what was your
career high in the in in the nfl when it
came to yards
like in the game you know 223 i think
i'm one of only four players to have
back-to-back 200-yard games i think i
had 223 against buffalo then i had 216
the next week against chicago
jesus christ man yeah i was i was i was
on one i was
he was on that [ __ ] hydroxy cut just
[ __ ]
wait wait wait wait what was that with
the dolphins over the dolphins yeah
[ __ ] dolphins